the left has no principles and so there
is the left this just whatever sign
helps them get power hey I'm Dave Rubin
and this is the Rubin report if you're
new here click the subscribe button and
make sure that the Bell is solid to get
all notifications and more importantly
joining me today is the founder and
president of Turning Point USA the
largest conservative college student
organization in the United States of
America as well as the host of the
charlie kirk podcast charlie kirk
welcome back at the reuben roohorse dave
glad to be here that was the longest
intro i've ever given well thank you all
and during that all in one breath were
also basically dressed exactly the same
here yes we have some agreements but we
also have some disagreements so there's
gonna be an odd mirror I think we've
actually started to agree on almost the
big every big thing over the last couple
years well a lot of the things actually
so you were on the show what it's about
two years or it's like January of 18 can
you area eighteen so that's like over a
year and a half ago basically and I've
gotten to know you quite well in the
last year and a half we we've toured
together usually with Candice Owens
obviously and I want to cover all new
stuff here but I do want to quickly just
talk about turning-point briefly because
when we do these events together and I'm
sure we've got some coming up in the
fall you always make a point of saying
to the audience a if you've got
questions and you disagree with us come
up first so we always take questions for
people that disagree with us first and
we treat them as respectfully as humanly
possible or at least as respectfully as
they treat us but also me and you have
some disagreements and we go up there
and we talk them out so how is it that
so many people on Twitter think you're a
fascist
what would a strange concept how is that
for a segue you see they're very good it
was right into it yeah what a strange
concept to hear the other side to give
people a platform that you totally might
fundamentally disagree with then have a
conversation about it see where you
might be able to build consensus find
the disagreements then find why you
disagree which is super important so you
did do you disagree because you have
different data inputs or do you disagree
cuz you're different philosophical
inputs to totally different things
yeah so for example someone might say
well I want universal health care
because it worked so well all across the
world
well okay let's talk about that and you
can maybe deconstruct some of the
failures of socialized medicine or I
want universal healthcare because I
believe healthcare is our right
that's different the right those are
very different otally different but and
then you're all the sudden have a
conversation and then what happens after
that conversation you've seen it Dave I
mean you spoke with us at University of
Connecticut you spoke with us at UC
Berkeley you subbed in for us up in the
Northeast New Hampshire right yes yes
you and Candice didn't show for that was
that right the one that I dealt with
those lunatics yourself thank you again
yeah of course and you got viral you did
go brilliantly I think and and Dave
you'll I think reinforced this every
time we get a chance to go to these
campuses and have these conversations
there seems as if at least with the
individual student and the people in the
room there's a level of respect for at
least our our worldview and our position
mm-hmm from even those that disagree
with us and we like to say that it's not
that these students are opposed to our
ideas and they're not exposing them at
all in the first place and just being
able to have this sort of marketplace of
ideas and you and I will disagree on
some things yeah sometimes which is
amazing I mean who wants to go listen to
a bunch of people say I agree me too I
agree you don't want that yeah by the
way what we called college right where
that is called College Sally and we're
gonna get into that because you and I
are having a major issue right now with
the with the big tech centric censorship
stuff which is it's a personal issue for
both of us as podcasters and youtubers
and the rest of it but it's also a
really serious philosophic issue but you
know one of the things that I always
find most interesting at the events that
we do is a lot of times they'll be like
a crew in the back of the room that
clearly is not there because they like
us but you know sometimes they'll sit
there respectfully but they'll kind of a
scowl on their face so they'll be
giggling or whispering to somebody gonna
make of it but but then by the end when
you're expecting that when you say to
them if you disagree with us come up
first a lot of them just kind of leave
because I think something does actually
happen over the course of the hour hour
and a half when they go oh these people
that I'm heard of heard or told her all
right or fascist or something they're
not all that bad and then suddenly they
feel sort of foolish well and what I
love is that we're sitting on stage we
have you we have a great Candice Owens
and they're here calling us racist
they're calling us bigoted they're
calling us backward thinking a homophobe
homophobic a homophobic right of course
[ __ ] right all these sorts of things
yeah
and all of a sudden listen to this
message of Western classical liberal
ideas of listening to other side and
opening up markets and the individual
matters the most we live in a great
country and Dave I have to say I am a
robber baron of one of the things that
you say I've stolen it probably thirty
times so as long as you credit me now
above more than fifty percent um I will
put out credit right now I credit you
sometimes a lot credit you right now
where you asked the audience you say who
here has it worse than your grandparents
and no Han I've never seen a handle up
yeah and isn't that a great just just
kind of visual representation of how
beautiful this country you know there's
one time just in the last few months so
I've asked that question hundreds of
times at this point and literally nobody
then about a month ago I was at Santa
Clara and I asked the question that
somebody for fellow subways it's even
better the guy raises his hand he says
that he's a Chinese immigrant to the US
and he moved here you know five or ten
years ago and that he has it worse than
his grandparents because the Communists
took all of his grandparents stuff and I
thought wow that's as good as it gets
that's it that is as good as you get but
that that sort of argument is not made
ever on college campuses through the
traditional institutional professor and
academic elites instead the
philosophical position that is
predominantly put towards students is
that America is a mistake the ideas that
you grew up with are flawed but we have
all the answers we and our couple
thousand professors in the Academy were
the smart ones we're the philosopher
kings that Plato used to talk about give
us the power and give us the trust to
how to run society and things will get
better and they focus on the inequality
they focus on the structural deficits
and of course there will always be
structural deficits I mean if a society
and ends up eradicating them I don't
think that's gonna happen in our
lifetime there'll always be outliers
there's gonna be people but generally
think you can have to kill a lot of
people to do that to look at Soviet some
yeah like we only have to kill 60
million people to try to you know get to
agreement well that's that's hard to
swallow on
and it didn't even work after that you
know and look at Communist China under
under Mao anyway so the the Academy is
is rooted in not teaching the other
right other ideas but teaching their
ideas the monolithic ideas and that's
why what we're doing and we love
bringing you to campus what we're doing
at Turning Point USA's have you so much
resonance and we have grown so
substantially since the last time you
and I sat down are you see our
conferences that was there all the
students there growing you know
exponentially and
was it your idea to just kind of so make
them more fun because I speak at all
sorts of stuff and there's definitely a
difference between going to a
turning-point event in the way the crowd
it feels a little bit almost like you're
at a pro wrestling match and I I mean
that in the most I mean that in the fun
way because even whatever they're
chanting and sometimes they're chanting
mag or whatever it is it's like they're
not doing it out of races or they're
doing it out of like let's have some fun
just with some of this and I don't even
think all of them are our pure mega
people or anything it's just like oh
let's not make politics just endlessly
painful and boring life to hear one more
lecture from someone like looks like the
shutting them in in Beach like okay I
got it
you know and that's fine you can listen
to those scholars but the traditional
conservative conference is just here's a
bunch of white papers here's how correct
we are let's look at these charts and
then you say okay I agree but what's
happening is that we're also in a
culture war and you go to these turning
point you know say events it's the music
it's the bright lights it's the t-shirt
cannons and all of a sudden you're
having fun yeah and who's that the left
is anti fun I mean they're anti comedic
and expression they're anti creativity I
mean everything is you're gonna defend
somebody I mean I'm surprised I really
am surprised we have these t-shirt
cannons that they have not said that we
are making fun of you know some sort of
victims of some sort of shooting because
we have t-shirt cannons well you guys
get it you just handed it well there we
go so that they'll they'll come after
that look to it with us later but you
know I'm joking of course but the point
is that we try to make it high-energy
and we do and because that our
conferences and our events you know grow
substantially so what did the
Conservatives do wrong if these
classical liberal to conservative ideas
are the right ones and I think I'm
pretty much with you on that at this
point well where did the Conservatives
screw up that they lost the Academy
there
the media they lost academia they lost
everything that led us to an entirely
brainwashed generation of Millennials
and then and then a group of se lefties
that are older than them that just
acquiesced to it out of sheer fear so we
did two things made a little wrong one
on policy philosophy which I think
you'll find interesting and the one just
kind of structurally unlike an
infrastructure side of what we've done
wrong
first of which I think that we lost a
lot of young people and a lot of people
that consider themselves liberals to
this day just over multi decades and
multi generations of identifying
themselves as that based on doing what
we now accuse the left of doing which is
for many years Republicans in the 70s
and 80s and I'm an avid Jellico
Christian Bible believing that angelical
Christian and so I have I think some
standing to say this the the right in
America was telling people how to live
their life mm-hmm
not everyone but boy did it sure sound
like that was that this is the correct
way this is the only way and then you're
mixing it's really close to mixing
deeply held religious beliefs and
government policy do you think they
meant it in that that's truly what they
wanted say the evangelicals or the
religious right or that it was purely a
political ploy because a lot of people
look back to george w bush's reelection
it's hard gay marriage like this wedge
issue which I don't think george w bush
specifically cared about gay marriage
but in that way it was a political tool
not necessarily an ideological it's
tough to say I mean I will I will speak
to the fact that I think conservatives
today on the right and you'll agree this
we have the moral high ground because
the ethos of the modern new conservative
movement is don't tell me how to live my
life I don't tell you how to live your
life don't take my stuff I'm not gonna
take your stuff that's really the ethos
of why we have the moral high ground as
that libertarian side I keep telling you
guys about just keep sticking with that
good I agree and there's some things
that I think yeah we'll get there with
more populist time but that's okay with
that being said so where did we go wrong
is we become we became the angry
librarian in the room in the 70s and 80s
don't have fun stop doing this and again
as an evangelical Christian that
believes
these I do believe all these ideas that
doesn't mean you have to put them forth
in government policy meaning that you
personally would want to partake in this
whether it's sex or drugs or and that's
fine
like for example we've talked I think
privately about you know drugs I think
you should be able put what you want in
your body I've never done drugs I don't
plan on doing drugs but why is it my
problem that you're doing that right so
that's a personal versus policy versus
kind of public policy so when you talk
to the more old-school conservatives on
that because so let's just forget all
the all the other drugs for a second
because I think there's a secondary
thing when you talk about the highly
addictive ones but let's just talk about
Marilyn are you list yeah just stop at
marijuana so on marijuana when you talk
to the more old-school conservatives I
simply don't understand the position
because I get it you guys want to have a
certain moral center that you don't want
to deviate against I understand that but
that Center then I mean this is what
you're getting to it then Bibi eighths
from your state's right stuff your
limited government stuff and it's like
those things are in constant conflict
then it's defend and why leave it to
Chuck Schumer to say that marijuana
should be a states rights issue like
when I heard him say that I was like oh
yeah like why [ __ ] yeah why give him
that yeah a little win yeah and so
here's my only contribution I think to
the whole marijuana debate where I come
from people should be able to do what
they want in their body but when it
starts to get into the glorification of
the substance that's where I'm gonna
push back and and that's where you not
gonna have an interesting discussions
you know
will it make society a better place over
the next twenty thirty years if more
people are doing marijuana maybe maybe
not I don't know I mean if you are doing
it instead of pharmaceuticals maybe but
if you have a bunch of fourteen year
olds that are you know consuming edibles
I don't know if that's a great thing
yeah alright however I that doesn't mean
that it should be illegal yeah and that
that's a really important thing and
that's where principles come in is you
can disagree with something
fundamentally and still think that other
people should be able to do it that
takes tolerance that takes maturity and
that takes us that that's what a civil
society is all about so are you pleased
then watching the way conservatives have
moved because when people say to me Oh
Dave you always go to these conservative
things and you know they secretly hate
gay people that's the most false
ridiculous thing
possibly think here yeah holy well I
never see it I mean I I mean I always
say this like I can't find them like you
can keep telling my and I found them
yeah I haven't I mean I did let's let's
let's talk about this for a minute you
and I spoke at Louisiana State
University now in the deep south in the
Bible Belt and you got a standing I
think I got more applause than you for
the record I'm just saying Lee and then
we also Candace Owens who got standing
up yeah I thought this place is supposed
to be backwards thinking and bigoted and
I mean I guarantee you we could we could
go to Universal family we could go to
the Lincoln Regan Day dinner in Alabama
and you would get that same sort of
response and so I haven't I'm speaking
at Liberty University in October and I
mean Jerry fall is an amazing guy and
they're gonna welcome you with open arms
and you get a standing ovation from them
now they have a biblical view of
marriage of which I have but your
biblical view of marriage does not have
to be what your public policy
prescription for marriages those are two
totally different things so then we're
so just let's go back to the question
then then where did the Conservatives
really get tripped up on this so I'm
glad to see it moving I'm what yeah I
think it's moving I get it but where did
they get screwed up and how do you fix
the remaining part of that it's where
the the evangelical right began to take
these deeply held religious beliefs and
see how popular they were in certain
parts of the country and then say well
let's just make it into that our public
policy platform and that's not what the
left is doing to us they're not taking
secular humanist trend very very kind of
I would say morally transient positions
now they're putting it in their public
policy positions they're doing it there
and we're accusing them on it right now
we're saying wait dude you can't tell me
how you can't tell me what bath I can't
have to use this bathroom or this or you
can't tell me how to live my life and I
wait wait a second a lot of Republic of
doing this back in the 70s and 80s do
you get a lot of Republicans pissed at
you when you acknowledge this because
this is this is a pretty big me a coal
pie thing for an evangelical Christian
and someone that's not even young we
shouldn't be afraid to admit mistakes
yeah I mean if we think that we've that
we've done brilliantly as a country
throughout the last 30 years on every
issue I mean come on that's a foolish
position to have and if you if you look
at it brilliant if Buckley was super
libertarian on certain issues really
libertarian I mean he was he was for the
legalization of marijuana
I mean William F Buckley that the
founder of National Review is for
legalization of marijuana and that's
that's a position a lot of people you
know are surprised to hear and yeah do I
get a lot of backlash I get disagreement
but I'd also I'm very and I qualified in
a very certain sense that I hold these
positions but there has to be in the way
that you create public policy if every
single individual says I'm gonna have my
worldview get put into law you have what
you have left is chaos
you've California where you have all
these little sub-tribes lobbying for the
most lunatic minority oppression
Olympics as you call it policy positions
and that's a really dangerous thing and
then you see how it ends up working
because my parents were visiting for the
last week and my dad was amazed at the
amount of tent cities we've got going up
in all these places these progressive
utopia's that are supposed to be the
friendliest to the people and everything
else you know yeah and so anyway that
that so that's the one thing I think
that conservatives are getting better at
now yeah I really do and I think
President Trump has done a great job of
this I have to say he's done a great job
of this he has been anti Dogma and I
love being I love the idea of crushing
pre-existing dogma or at least
challenging it because if some dogmas
good and it should be upheld there's
some things that shouldn't be so for
example one piece of dogma in our
society is hard work is a good thing
okay
that's good great let's keep that but
then there's other pieces of dogma that
let's just declare war in every country
that looks at us funny really that's
what Republicans should believe mmm-hmm
like after the horrendous Iraq war and
the endless Afghanistan war we should
still just be more happy and
trigger-happy at every corner I don't
think so isn't it strange now how the
media is sort of painting conservatives
as the anti-war party and a bizarre
sense so like Helen tell me policy is
like you know all against war and now
they're making it sound like she's a
conservative it's I thought this goes
back to what Dennis Prager talks about
the left has no principles and the Fed
is the left
there's just whatever side helps them
get power and I there's this what the
mayor of Baltimore she goes on
television the day that the president
Trump correctly decided not to execute a
missile strike that would have killed
120 Iranians she says well this is a
huge sign of weakness against President
and I saw this I said only president
Democratic Democrat to accuse him of not
declaring a war on a sovereign it is
that his gift more than anything else if
you were to you know him obviously but
if you were to whittle away everything
else is that the gift that somehow he
has that pinpoint precision ability to
find out what their weaknesses and get
them to use it against themselves
constantly it's one of his greatest
gifts I think he has a lot of them I
just he's able to expose the hypocrisy
within them so brilliantly and even
deeper than that I I think it's a I
think it's a very interesting thing he's
able to pull out the radicalism within
the left and whether it's a good thing a
bad thing things a good thing as you can
see who they really are I think it's a
bad thing because I'm more people than
become radical you know and that sort of
is where we're at right now right like
oh my god he's kind of exposing the hell
out of him and and actually you know
it's funny every time he exposes them
for something I'm like oh that thing
that I was talking about as a lefty like
when I still considered myself left him
like oh yeah yeah that's the thing I was
talking about three years ago now it's
just burst forth for everyone to see but
it is a catch-22 right because on one
hand you're exposing it that's good
sunlight on the other hand then it's
suddenly well there's equal to us in
this well consequence databases so then
President Trump exposes the radicalism
which is good so we can see who these
people really are we can see who ill on
all my Rasheeda Talib Ayanna Presley and
Alexander Kashia Cortes we can see who
they really are and the ideas they hold
which is good that's always a good thing
but then what happens is the media hates
Trump so much they modernize these ideas
they also make it oh it's not that bad
that Elon Omar's says that some people
did something about 9/11 it's not that
bad that Alexandria Kai's do Cortes
calls herself a socialist and then they
almost make it palatable and we're
digestible and you have more people then
embrace these radical positions and
that's that I guess that's that's where
we are i I'm a little troubled by that
and I do want to make a really
interesting point that I want everyone
listening to this and watching this to
think about which is what makes this
particular struggle versus leftist
Marxism and kind of Western society
values so unique it's mean I don't know
might in my knowledge
never happened before almost every one
of these revolutions that we can point
to her last hundred years the Russian
Revolution the Chinese Revolution
every time that Marxists have taken over
a government and you see it through the
universities that similar but they are
always pro nation state like the Russian
Revolution they were pro Russia mmm-hmm
they were that's interesting you see
they were there for the country and so
they were able to win over the
countrymen because they're well we love
the country more we want this is so
different they're actually trying to
assume power by being against the
country yeah this the founding
principles were able the founders are
earlier let's take down all the statues
it's Anthea linskey I al instant talked
about embracing and he was essentially
telling people how to lie to get the
power that essentially the doctrine of
saw linskey but Olinsky talked about
using the main symbols and the main
sayings of a country to get to power and
never diminish them Betsy Ross oh my
gosh yeah I heard about that so Saul
linski would have said Colin Kapernick
you're a fool you should have embraced
the Betsy Ross flag and said she was a
feminist and she would be upset with
where America is today that's what Saul
linski with us all right
we've never worked with this sort of
insurgency what do you think it's
possible I mean the the place that I've
sort of gotten to them is okay so let's
just say we disagree with ya most
everything they say right I don't you
know I try not to impugn people's
motives I tend to think at this point
that their motives are bad and that they
really know that you know they're
they're being owned every every other
day you know there's so II some clip of
them just saying something awful and not
knowing what they're saying or they
can't respond to a basic question are
you for left-wing terrorism you know
like they can't say no I'm not for
terrorism etc etc how much of it do you
think is just that they genuinely and I
hate to say this because this is not how
I operate a get people that I disagree
with politically but that they genuinely
just want to create chaos that that
their the chaos makers and then they'll
have say the Warrens or the Bernese
clean it up at a nicer level or
something like that but they're just on
the ground just creating as much chaos
as possible depends on you're talking
about so if you talk about con talk
about those days before yeah this
allowed to leave Presley
Tezz and I'm thinking I'm forgetting one
more Omar yeah so you get to first ask
the question is do they want what's best
for America and that's a really hard
question to answer
and I it depends like what you mean by
right what's best right but I do you
think here's another great cruiser
question do you think they're thankful
to be in America like do you think
they're overflowing with gratitude I
don't get that impression I get
bitterness it seems that they're bitter
that when they're walking the halls but
they're committed I mean you see it yeah
you see it right that they're there on a
mission that there's anger driving them
that there's something they believe that
this system that we're living in this
beautiful country is so much opportunity
so much blessing so much overflowing
abundance for all people that they see
something that I don't see and that you
don't see and of course we see problems
right we see our inner cities ruined we
see all these sorts of things but we
also understand that on the moving
average this country's been unbelievable
and continues to be in the rien bracing
those ideas will make it more so I don't
feel as if that they're thankful to be
in this country and so there are always
people though in every major
civilization like this that kind of to
use the Joker term just kind of want to
see the world burn mm-hmm and I don't
know if that's them or not but it sure
they sure sound like that at times and I
I find it that they use every single
instance of political exploitation
opportunity to try to advance their own
political agenda to get further into
power and it's a very dangerous position
because any sort of cross-examination of
these people they immediately excuse you
of the most vile things yeah you're
racist I mean it's always it's always
you're racist you're a [ __ ] it's too
bad because I could not care less about
their gender or their color ever ever
interview look when I criticize them I'm
not criticizing them because of their
race I'm criticizing because what they
say in their worldview and they just
happen to be that race no I think this
is an afterthought I mean it would be
the same thing of Adam Schiff was saying
I mean I've had plenty of sex pants by
the way right I've had plenty of fun at
Chuck Schumer's expense a Nancy Pelosi
expense but the one time you accuse
these other people you know receipt it
to leave and Presley
Cortez you accrues that squad if you
will all of a sudden you're called these
horrible names and you know it's too bad
about it is that there is really is amid
the world there is but the more that
that term is thrown around flippantly
and just so kind of haphazardly it
cheapens real racism so i know you don't
want to help the democrats but if you
were say a saner democrat than them if
you were just a little more of a
moderate and it's so funny because now
Pelosi who really is pretty far left in
another itself yeah but now she's being
framed as the centrist democrat even
though she's certainly not the type of
liberal because her answer is always
government that that i would care about
but it let's say there were a couple
are there any democrats that you think
are sort of more blue dog older that guy
knows on the stage from maryland Delaney
yeah he was he talked about he was just
on the wrong stage i mean i mean he was
talking about this country has been
great to a lot of people we need to get
back to national service you're saying
some things actually agreed with so okay
so then if you were talking about yeah
right so the one guy maybe Hickenlooper
but then he said some nutty stuff so one
guy okay but if you were talking
directly to him and you wanted to help
this guy regain the party but what would
you tell some ways I'd to wouldn't you
before a guy that wants Trump to
obviously win again but in some ways I
want a functioning second party like in
some ways I want to party that will step
up and say you know what we do want
regulatory reform you know what we do
want to fund our military look it I'd
I'd be nice yeah like we don't want open
borders how about that how'd that and I
think Delaney could come to a agreement
with that
what would my advice be to him I mean
you have to fight the radicals within
your own party before you even focus on
you know president Trump because you've
got something very very dangerous within
your own party I think and Who am I to
give advice to the left I mean I want
President Trump to win in a massive
landslide and I believe is on his way to
win for many different reasons this
being one of the contributing factors
the fact of how radical the left has
become but it's not exclusive to that
but I don't think that's gonna happen
Dave I'm gonna tell you why
well I've seen no evidence of it you'd
think that having Trump win an election
might have caused a little self
reflection so here's the question when
you and I go to college campus is a
turning point USA with turning-point USA
are the students more like the squad or
more like Delaney the students that come
to us - well I got that like us or
radical
tester type oh no their of course
they're much more like the squad of
course that's the leading indicator yeah
that's the harbinger whatever happens on
college campuses will soon happen in the
halls of Congress the leading indicator
of a culture is what happens on college
campuses
ilan Omar AOC they got educated on these
college campuses or lack thereof or
indoctrinated they got radicalized yeah
and then they get set forth and they're
committed they have their marching
orders if you look at a prototype of
what the campus creates the University
if there was a formula of what they're
trying to put into the world it is
Alexandria
Acacio Cortez everything about her
constantly wrong but never in doubt
consistently challenging our history
totally questioning any sort of power
structure at be no belief in national
sovereignty at all and chaos chaos chaos
that's the university that's what
they're creating all right so you don't
want to help them that much I know I
mean I would like to see people like
Delaney you know take take root but
here's the other point so here's the
other thing that no one talks about
which i think is an interesting point
which is in politics you're always kind
of looking at who's my base how am i
catering to that base and so when Donald
Trump ran for the presidency and you
went down the Golden escalator he did
something that actually made the
radicals the main Democrats become more
radically saying how is that possible he
stole their base away from them so he
stole ten million Democrats that are
Catholics that are union workers that
are electricians that are middle class
people that have voted Democrats since
1970 and now they're registered Trump
people and they go to the rallies I mean
you look at the data that I've actually
the Trump rallies just amazing
percentage of registered Democrats
Panetta's and they end up voting for
Trump they think nothing of it well
they're basically getting the
disaffected Bernie people so that saw
how corrupt the Democrats like blow it
all up so then what happens if the
Democrats all this and have 10 million
less Democrats mind you Republicans bled
a little they bled some suburban voters
mm-hm they bled some you know
upper-middle class voters just because
they didn't like Trump style but the
offset was generally positive in the
states that really mattered
which were the traditional Democrats
Democrats look at their kind of roster
like oh my gosh we're down to ten
million voters and then some lunatic
proposes in a room well instead of
trying to win those people back why
don't we go one more people in Malibu
and Manhattan Oh a great idea that is
yeah and then they start embracing these
horrendously radical ideas as if they
can get more people maybe they can I
mean I've been proven wrong before but
somehow they can win another ten million
people around the green New Deal
universal health care for illegals
complete and total open borders shutting
down people you disagree with
prosecuting people that dare say
something critical of a member of
Congress which represent Rico Wilson
said yeah oh yeah that was a real or or
you know you know Dave I've done a lot
of traveling I have to say a kitchen
table issue in Pennsylvania is making
sure that the Boston bomber can vote
they're all about it right now it's like
their one issue voters on that it's
amazing how many people in Harrisburg
Pennsylvania come up through they said
Charlie whatever candidate makes sure
that terrorists can vote they got my
vote to make of course I'm being
facetious the more they look but
audience they cater but does that tell
you really how insidious this way of
thinking is so like during the first
debate when they all spoke Spanish and
to me it was the word fringing the worst
sort of pandering it would have been
like if this was 1940's and we had an
influx of Irish Americans and they were
up we're gonna give you all a punch at
all it's like what are you guys doing
but it's the worst sort of pandering and
yet they keep going to it so it's almost
as if the ideology actually overrides
what you're saying would just be sort of
sound political you know maneuvering to
win an electorate do whatever they need
to do to assume power that's the left
and so if you come from the the
acceptance that they're trying to
deconstruct this country then it all
starts to make sense
that why would you want to have open
borders you want to destroy the
sovereignty why would you want to give
away stuff you can so horrible and we
should let everyone in by the way this
is what I can't understand a couple
things you got me on this the Democrats
they were this horrible country
albertson one of the worst why the hell
would you want to be president of that
country like I hate this country
yeah I want to be president of it that's
a really interesting that's how good
they are that's right no but they want
to save us from ourselves right because
they're on the philosopher-king that
yeah we'll save us the second thing is
this is if we were really this racist
bigoted homophobic horrendous country
what are millions of people trying to
come here and just from a more broad
standpoint we take it half the world's
immigrants every single year we're
taking a million legal immigrants every
single year well the most accepting
generous benevolent country ever to
exist in a history of the world
I think we're overly generous at times
actually I think our generosity actually
come back to bite us at times I think
that Trump has brought rational
self-interest back to the conversation
of the nation-states they're just real
quick on the immigration stuff and then
I really do want to get to something
ours disagree on but on the immigration
stuff look I get it there are videos of
Obama of Pelosi of Chuck Schumer of Bill
Clinton all saying virtually the exact
same things that Trump now says and
Trump is considered racist now I get it
Trump also has a strange intonation and
inflection when he speaks and he can be
a little sloppier on some of the
language or may be intentionally
inflammatory or yeah and that's fine I'm
it doesn't even matter which way you
look at it the point is that what he's
actually saying is not different really
than what Obama's saying I even just
this morning I tweeted out a clip about
Obama saying virtually the same things
that Trump says now do you think there's
anything that could ruin can do if you
think his policies around immigration
are moral and just and reasonable is
there anything you could do just around
the language that might ease up some of
this tension yeah I mean the one
suggestion that I've made publicly and
I'll make it again is we have to own the
legal immigrant I loved when Trump
talked about the big door I want to hear
more about the door I wanted him to say
wall and door that'd be just my one
piece of recommendation because I was
watching this ridiculous clip on Twitter
the other day and the left the left mmm
they shadowbox and make it seem as if if
you're accusing border jumpers and line
cutters I don't call them immigrants
they're border jumpers and line cutters
because you know minimun grayness
someone wastes their turn that comes to
this country correctly which is why
we're seeing tons of studies now where
legal immigrants first-generation
illegal immigrants are the most anti yes
illegal immigrant a way to process their
to get a green but all these amazingly
hard difficult things we can make that
easier but the second thing is the left
they make it seem as if if you're
against line cutters and border jumpers
you're somehow against
legal immigrants mm-hmm and I take the
position and some people on the right
disagree this position I think we should
have more legal immigrants I think we
should be the Kentucky basketball of
immigrants I want the smartest richest
most aspirational creative people in the
world to come here that are under the
age of 35 this should be the laboratory
of excellence for the world I want the
best Koreans Indonesians Somalians
Germans I don't care where you're from i
if you have aspiration come to America
that should be the advertisement and boy
this Donald Trump is great in marketing
he could sell that in a second could
mean he could do a world tour just on
the legal immigration tour and I think
that would be the media would find a way
here's the link sign up I think the
media obvious on the Left would be
totally again for you know okay they'd
be building the wall for him kid you
know but the last thing is this is look
if he illegals were voting Republican
and they were tend to vote Republican
the Democrats would already have the
wall built and say anyone who opposes
the wall is against the black community
right they would write some ways in it
yeah but actually is it is correct that
open borders hurt the black community
believe it or not but that's another
another whole thing alright so I want to
back up to one other thing in there and
then let's get to the tech stuff which
is super important on how sort of
conservatives are people on the right
have to sort of widen the net right now
how do you think the messaging could be
about making room for secular
conservatives are secular Republicans so
someone like Heather McDonald who I've
had on the show who is she's a religious
I think I think she's an atheist yes she
said I find pissed petitionary prayer
futile and I love Heather I heard that
is come on yeah they disagree every
other okay but you want to live in the
same society as her and you probably
agree worsen I probably religious
fundamentalist so but so but I think and
I when I was on Candace's show under you
I brought this up that if that there's
such lunacy on the left that to me all
the right has to do well all
conservatives have to do is just be at
every turn be a tiny bit better like you
don't have to be you know to be like now
I just a little bit better what do you
think conservatives or Republicans or
whatever can do for the disaffected
lefty that still is secular maybe has
some religious belief but it's not sort
of a corner tenon or whatever it is what
do you think that people on the right
I have to give the conservatives credit
I think Donald Trump's done a lot of
that I mean Donald Trump has been
amazingly embracing of the of angelical
community but he himself and I don't
want to speak for him was definitely
more secular yeah right I mean he was
not running a campaign like Mike
Huckabee a Rick Santorum was in 2016
would I think you would agree yeah for
sure it's much more based on ideas in
the revitalization in the nation-state
and those guys actually have very little
influence now over modern Republican
politics yeah and and look I agree with
again I want to just make sure I
reinforced this I agree with them on
basically a lot of things are saying
personally and now my pro-life position
I book is is I could defend that from a
secular lens if you've got another four
hours weekend we might dive in or you
could talk to Lila Rose about that yes
Lila is really great we've done that one
I know it's amazing pockets I listened
to it a couple times she was really
really good on it but the the thing that
I find really interesting about this is
that the Republicans are becoming the
tolerant ones we really are and it's
it's the Republican conservative ones
that have the most intellectual
diversity that have the most I believe
it's gonna have the most religious
diversity where we're trending towards
that and I like to think that turning
point USA has really been on the cutting
edge of this I think we've been on the
cutting edge of it yeah listen I go to
turn boy there are kids in yarmulkes
there are black kids there are Muslim
kids there are trans people and we have
a we have a spokesman Rob Smith who's a
veteran of our country happens to be gay
black super articulate you know we can't
so ins was with us for a while and did
an amazing job I mean I would like to
think that we're practicing what we're
preaching I would like to think that and
also on doing events with you is so fun
because it's one thing to say you're the
tolerant one and then you're the only
one I think you know but it's fun guys
than you and I will disagree on a couple
things but the marketplace of ideas in
the collision of ideas it also keeps you
you know like any muscle if it atrophies
if you don't use it atrophies the same
thing goes with your policy positions in
your politics and I really believe part
of the reason why the left has become so
radical is they haven't had to debate
yeah they got they got fat because it
was so easy to call it ver and racist
and sit back yeah
so they ALC Alexandra Cortez has she
ever gone on a centre-right platform
that's a really good question is it is I
I know of no knowledge of it ever since
that one woman asked her three tough
questions about and she said Palestine
was occupying Israel or something she
has done nothing but friendly media yeah
where I would love to sit down with her
and even though I've gone after her
obviously I would treat her of course
with respect I know you would and I have
to and I would ask her direct questions
and I'd hope she would ask questions out
of me and so I the one thing I think is
really important that I get far too
often the question I get a lot in
college campuses and then we can get
into the tech stuff is that students
that are in the middle there there they
come after this this is the best case
scenario times but it's not correct
where they say well yeah the left has
gone out of control but the right has
also gone really out of control I say to
myself what do you mean there is no
moral equivalency between the two where
is right wing and Tifa where is what
they'll tell you it's the KKK they
there's 45 of them and every time they
try to materialize anywhere its
unilateral uniformed and overwhelming
denouncement of these people right just
out of control - no yeah I think we
should just hit that though because I
don't know if what happened if what
happened a couple weeks ago with with
ice yeah it would be okay well we have
or with Andy even right with Andy no go
ahead on
I mean if either one of those things had
come out of the right whatever that is
whether there was CNN Sunday night's
special yeah we they'd be having a town
hall where Marco Rubio would be getting
strung up I mean that's right yeah and
so they virtues signal a lot better than
us but what I'm trying to say is I'm not
trying to say we're like better people
and we deserve all this but boy our
worldview is better than them right now
a hundred percent because if you're a
member of Congress and you're asked a
specific question will you denounce
antifa which if for all intents and
purposes in my mind is a domestic terror
organization there are domestic terror
organization they should be treated as
such how do you assault a journalist
like that with masks with concrete
milkshakes send him to a hospital and
not be called a domestic terror you have
or even organization you have a
hierarchy you have a common meeting
place I mean all the stuff that because
yeah they're doing that dirty work
FBI there's like a checklist that the
FBI has and what a terror group is they
qualify all the domestic terror group I
mean they have specific targets right
they they all this sort of thing and yet
total silence amongst the left
complete and total silence and I'm
rooting I'm rooting for people like
Delaney and Andrew yang is Andrew yang
denounced it yeah Andrew yang had the
best tweet and this that then we'll get
to the tech stuff the best tweet he said
and I think it was just kind of this
very interesting observation he's a iq
that's amazing he's a really smart guy
he's misguided in the ubi thing but
that's okay and I said um I noticed
conservatives follow a lot more liberals
on Twitter than liberals follow
conservatives on Twitter did you see
this yeah I thought and I said he he's
getting there
give him like give him five more months
in the circus he's going to be very he's
gonna have a different view of the left
than he did a year and AD I actually I
completely agree and then we're gonna
get to the disagreements up but I'm with
you on that because he keeps you know I
had him in here and I think he's and
then Miley your interview with him was
fantastic Thank You Lee good not
necessary to say but it's fake honest he
I think I think you're basically right
because even when I asked him what his
progressive politics were everything he
said was about equality you know I'm for
gay marriage or something like that and
it's like but that's not progressive
anymore because we've progressed to it
we've progressed to equality so in my
view he really is an old-school liberal
and yes on some of the big government
stuff and whatever you think about you
bi he's not there but I think once he's
done with this evil machine he's gonna
in a weird way he could end up being
more right than I think said most
liberals I think that probably is where
I'll end up low weight let's okay fine
all right I want to move to the disagree
on we've been too nice to each other
here we are you wrote a piece in The
Washington Post about big tech a couple
weeks ago and when everyone that's
watching this knows that where I'm at
right now is the libertarian side of me
that thinks that the market can can
solve everything or at least that the
market is the best way yes just solve
problems not that they're always going
to be solved but that's the best way
that's being pushed to its limit the
rubber is meeting the road I think the
tech companies have gotten so out of
control
with the bannings with the shadow
bannings with the
D monetization x' with algorithms that
nobody seems to know how to control or
are being manipulated and i could go on
and on with it selling other things your
argument basically was yeah i don't want
the government doing anything but here
we are that's that's the but and now the
but of course is where that's where the
problem start kicking in if you hold an
ideal that markets are supposed to solve
these things so i'm not there it's not
there it's a really tough conversation
dude i'm so glad we're having it because
I'm a Milton Friedman guy I'm a free
market free people wait New York Times
had him on the cover he said he's Indian
alright yeah zero you're right that was
the most ridiculous piece yeah that I've
seen my dad forty years he's had the New
York Times I think even longer than I've
been born he had it for like forty five
years still subscribed nothing like
seeing his son's head this was all right
dishonest piece of journalism ever seen
you have one guy like one guy yeah and
it's just this pablum thousands of words
of nonsense anyway that that's a
different thing at a different type
invited the author another field Milton
Friedman yeah Milton Friedman guy I'm a
Thomas soul guy I believe markets do
solve solutions for those you that are
listening or watching that aren't sure
what my view of markets are it's that
free people exchanging goods in a free
society voluntarily mutually cooperating
as they see fit will benefit society
benefit the individual and that that's
essentially a market so a couple things
in order for a market to operate you
also believe in private property that's
a big thing so you have impartial courts
that can adjudicate differences so
you're not an anarchist I'm not an
anarchist Adam Smith talked about the
importance of impartial courts because
you're gonna have differences of
properties and not just physical
property but intellectual property and
all that and also of course the price
system that's really really important
Milton Friedman talks how prices are the
language how we communicate with each
other so if tomorrow Starbucks made
every single cup of coffee twenty five
dollars which is not inconceivable
considering they're uh they're gonna
lower the prices exactly that the upward
trajectory that they're on for coffee
there's there's something to be said
that less people lie that coffee and so
that's how you communicate no one
actually might open some people might
open their voice would be upset but the
the silent regression from buying their
coffee will be reflected in their
balance sheet and that's how we
communicate value to value prices are
super important
so I think the first thing we talk about
tech is we all suck we first admit we
really don't have a market in tech
there's a couple reasons behind this and
then we have to talk about some of the
problems that I think everyone admits
first of all there's a lot of cronyism
that exists between the big tech
companies right now whether be
government contracts whether it be far
too extended patents that are given to
Google we need to think about this I
think that patents in a lot of ways are
anti-free market and I think we should
shrink the window of how long some of
these patents are so you said it the
best mm-hmm Google has this algorithm
that no one can figure out right but
they also have a patented and they have
a patent for a very long time and so if
it were to be put off the patent market
well it's also made public mm-hmm and if
someone could compete against it that's
an interesting thing to think about that
there could be a further that they're
actually hiding behind some of the
government favors that are given it
right so it's a weird place to be though
because you're sort of asking for
government interference I'll get this
back-end freedom so let's have let's go
to what we want yeah I think let's look
I always tell our team at Turning Point
USA every every time what does success
look like well Charlie's success looks
like 1400 high school kids in DC in
August great how do we get that we work
backwards to where we are today let's
let's do that why not take me on this
voyage what does success look like fair
free and open platforms with different
ideas can express themselves multiple
tech companies not four but dozens of
tech companies competing for our
interests that are able to you know have
these ideas present hopefully an
improving product over time and
hopefully a search engine that doesn't
have 92% of the market share I don't
think that's a healthy thing I just
don't I think even 40% would be a lot 92
so that that's where a success would
look like a disaggregation let's call it
that right decentralization I think
that's probably a fair so you would
agree at that right now
and also you not having to battle
YouTube non-stop and you're not having
to do all these things you actually
focus on content creation I've asked you
Dave how many hundreds of hours have you
spent of wasted energy on this stuff oh
it's been that I mean I have to fight
them publicly constantly it's like it's
not sighs you right I well it's not fun
it's it's not that it's it's a no well
it's bad business because I'm voting cow
content that
I end up losing money on I'm in a weird
way there are times where I'm doing the
producers the more things that I make
the more money I lose yes which is not
fun but also it's just publicly it's not
fun to have to attack the your own your
own platform but okay so so far I'm with
you on the ideas but now we're we're
going to have our problem is here so
here's the question a functional part is
the the question is so let's say we
deregulate some of the patents
definitely but is it enough and I'm at a
place right now where Tiger Carlson says
something really interesting to me and
really stuck with me said Charlie we
need to think about this who is more
powerful the IRS or Google and I
immediately said the IRS because that's
what we conservatives believe like we
believe that government has uniform
power and I defended it I thought pretty
well Google doesn't have the power audit
school can't put you in prison you know
these IRS could do all those sorts of
things Ryan IRS can wreck your business
and Tucker retorted with a really
interesting thing he said well but
Google can't shut down your business
yeah I guess that's right and I debater
a little bit and Google can manipulate
entire society bleed some that might not
be true and we went through the whole
litany of how powerful Google was and I
thought about it for months and I think
it's really important thing that we
conservatives do we actually are always
challenging our positions I think that's
what's so healthy about our movement and
it hit me about a month and a half ago
when I was using I had my laptop open
and I my gmail account watching YouTube
you know I'm a Google Calendar yeah and
I said my goodness they know everything
about me the IRS doesn't know crap
the IRS knows a couple bank statement
you know my taxes my bank statements
that's a very small picture of my actual
activity and I thought to myself and I
might this computer open I said what if
one engineer in Google just flipping
through Twitter and saw one of my tweets
praising President Trump and he said
screw this charlie Kirk guy I'm going
and he goes to work tomorrow and he
decides to look at everything about me
mm-hmm do we know that's not happening I
mean I think we can go into the
assumption that it is happening it's
really scary that's more power than the
NSA has and by the way we know that
Google is so slanted in the wrong
direction ideologically we know they've
shown regret for not doing enough in
2016 we know the political imbalance
their political contributions were over
a million dollars to Hillary Clinton
zero dollars to Donald Trump in 2016 as
far as political contributions
they fired James de Maury so here's the
question is is there in place for the
federal government to get engaged or
involved tinker around the edges or
chain or do something to change the way
that this is currently happening and the
piece I wrote in The Washington Post was
first admitting how this could go wrong
so let's just can I start there is that
okay yeah yeah so so that's why that's
why I brought up the piece because I
think you didn't try to at least
acknowledge yeah this is the freaking
murky road that this thing is struggling
with this because I'm a free market so
great I believe this guys see the
beautiful society created by the free
market and I say but what about this
these companies I'm struggling that was
a good thing to struggle because then
you actually might find reasonability
somewhere and so the first piece is
let's see how this could go wrong okay
more times than not when you apply
regulation on a very very big company
the regulation get ends up getting
written by those companies the
regulation gets lobby for the by those
companies
there's last-minute middle the night
changes being put by senators and K
Street law firms and lobbying lobbyists
that end up actually benefiting the very
company that's supposed to regulate
right it ends up hurting the competition
that's trying to upstart cuz they can
never sign with the regulations okay so
now you're so far you're giving me stuff
that I'm with you I'm talk about why we
opened up with this G all right
and so let's let's took it was a very
agreeable example this dodd-frank
dodd-frank for those I don't know that
are watching this was a banking
regulation bill passed out of out of the
2008 financial crisis authored by Chris
Dodd and Barney Frank to try to regulate
the big banks to try to never allow the
2008 financial crisis to happen again
but essentially what it would be is he's
like okay I lost my arm in a horrible
moto moto motorcycle accident and I'm
taking pepto-bismol for a stomach it's
like the complete wrong your treatment
is it there nothing to do with this so
they apply the wrong treatment to an
ill-advised poorly analyzed problem and
what ended up happening was the big five
or six banks Goldman Wells Fargo Bank of
America JPMorgan Chase you know these
these massive massive banks that have
trillions and trillions hundreds it
tends a billion tens of trillions of
dollars of
that's collectively they lobby for
regulation that they understand that
they can comply with now they're even to
bigger to fail and what has happened
you now have foot Wells Fargo you have
boa you've JPMorgan with stock prices
that have never been higher with more
power than ever had and what did
dodd-frank do we have seen a massive
decrease and decline in community
banking massive because for the bank the
local bank of Sacramento let's just take
a local bank of Sacramento that might
have 250 million dollars in deposits and
they might do a couple min let's say 12
million in revenue you know they've got
some good loans out healthy balance
sheets all that but all of a sudden a
federal regulator walks in with an
encyclopedia of new regulation they have
to comply with and they say well this is
gonna cost at $800,000 in Lok Lak and
they're well sorry this is the new law
well $800,000 for JPMorgan was called
lunch that's nothing I mean it's nothing
then so what ends up happening is that
penalize it so I'm admitting I'm being
bought in so that so this is a huge
concession on your part of a piece right
I'm being vulnerable of how I've come to
this because I first want to just tell
the audience that I'm not dealing in
absolutes here at all I'm dealing it
very much of there's there's there's
context and there's texture to this so
anyway so how regulation could be a
weapon use and fit you saw this with
Facebook though you saw this a Facebook
where Facebook actually put forth this
proposal of how to protect people's
privacy
sounds like for 450,000 pages of garbage
it was basically written by you know
Sheryl Sandberg and Mark Zuckerberg how
their company can thrive and rule the
world okay that's stupid
so then the question is how do we get to
that success and I think what I wrote in
the piece is the number one thing that
we can do is change section 602 I think
that's the number I get it's the 206 or
602 I can be dyslexic at times so I
think it's 602 in the technology code
that was passed the 1990s that allows
these technology platforms to hide
behind the label of being a platform
when they're really acting like a
publisher so the Rubin report right the
any of these come
you guys are publishers right correct me
if I'm wrong
yes I'm responsible I'll get the
contents right so if you look I put a
brother and say something horribly
libelous about somebody and publish it
behind your name you could be held
accountable for that libel suit okay now
a platform right a platform is supposed
to be an open forum where no one could
be held accountable to it however where
they get around it is where they have
these community standards right right
now she's the sneaky way of oh we're
gonna kind of curb out who we don't
right exactly one is so trying to break
outside of the binary box since the
piece I've thought of this more and I've
gotten some really good feedback on it
there can be a third box created - it's
like you can have a platform publisher
and then social network cuz they're not
either they're definitely acting like a
publisher they're pretending to be a
platform but why not create a third box
and have an internet Bill of Rights
that's an interesting idea
I'm not saying that's a hundred percent
what I believe but why not because when
you're consuming so much information
online and so many people are there live
loads are online and we're gravitating
towards online what's to say that there
shouldn't be that kind of third box and
so there's a very aggressive community
of says regulate these companies for all
the regulators Adam it's very tempting
to do that because you want to seek
vengeance against these companies that
are doing these horrible horrible things
but my whole thing right here is that
something needs to change government -
Lee we're at that point mm-hmm what that
something is I'm open-minded - I
proposed in the Washington Post piece
that got a ton of play I've got more
males in that piece I think than any
other thing I've written because you got
the six the 602 code is the opening you
that's where you that's where I think we
have to change it so okay so I like the
platform verse publisher debate and I
think you're right they are acting now
as publishers not open platforms so I
think there's something there I think
where I would still be struggling is
okay so we even I can get you with you
on the internet but all right so I would
love that if you're if you're a well
publisher let's say if you're a platform
as they're pretending to be and you have
certain things to abide by but now that
but so that sounds good right road to
hell is paved with good intentions now
we've got something that sounds good but
then to enforce it what are you going to
do what is
going to do suddenly you have a
gajillion bureaucrats running around
these companies making sure that they're
doing all of those things and it's like
well do the middle management government
bureaucrats have any insight into how
these companies operate internally I
could tell you what you do you create a
division in the Department of Justice
that's focus on in an Internet Civil
Rights it's no different than free
expression that was challenged in the
seventies and eighties and a lot of
different in the gay community was you
know there was a huge there was huge
controversy in the 1980s in California
in particular a lot of lawsuits that
stemmed out of that there was a creation
eventually in the department justice
that focused on said how is it any
different Dave when you get the kind of
penalisation that you have done on
social media or when Crowder gets
demonetized
how is that not a violation of your
freedom of expression and some of us
that would have private company I don't
want to force that Baker to bake the
cake of course I completely until the
understand that but then you are
publisher you're discriminating mm-hmm
if you want the point of being a
publisher is you don't take everyone's
piece yeah right right right that's the
whole that's that's the whole idea of
being a publisher and so the the other
the other interesting thing Dave a
question to challenge you is when at
what point
what's the breaking point for you
because because what if Google showed us
all up Shapiro Crowder knowles Clavin
Daily wire me Prager overnight would
then we say we go after them with
government and here's the other question
I thought let me jumpin them right so
I've been posing this actually when I
cuz this is what I've been talking about
mostly at colleges lately and I posed
that question if they were to digitally
assassinate me today if they just all of
them just agree Twitter down youtube
down Facebook down and Instagram down
would that be a violation of my civil
right and I think it's as close as you
can possibly get to yes they could they
could just take you out of what the new
public sphere is and and especially the
way that technology is evolving so fast
you could almost argue that your ability
to be on those platforms in some weird
way is almost paramount than your
ability to just exist yeah on a day to
day basis which is a sort of you know
very philip k dick to think
is so my question for you Dave is are we
there yet and if not when will we be and
do then that I'm there okay so let's
let's say I see it so so Tucker and I
have done this several times on his show
so let's say I grant you that then
explain this to me
Trump happens to be favorable to some of
the people that you're mentioning here
he's he's on the right side of this
issue I would say what happens now Trump
loses in 2020 you've got President
Elizabeth Warren who wants its code 230
my guys were telling me by the way not
602 C we fact check I'm here the rubric
Wars is that wasn't even dyslexia that
was just a made-up yeah it wasn't made
up it was music I'm sorry I got a lose
number you've just lost all credibility
for a and I really thought you were
doing well this hour no all right now
we've got president Elizabeth Warren who
would be more than happy as a far left
progressive to do everything that she
can to have the government take over
everything and now you've already handed
her this power now I think I know your
answer is gonna be she's gonna do it
anyway whether Trump moves on it or not
the left will come for it anyway but
that still seems crazily dangerous to me
you had a terrible pressure hold it
depends on how we structure this in a
way again I think I think the challenge
is whenever possible we're going back to
the doctrine of Adam Smith so here's the
question Dave private property you have
private property rights don't you we all
do yeah
so aren't all your videos you put on
YouTube your property and you've
monetized them and so under the Adam
Smith doctrine of markets you well
technically I don't know if I actually
just honestly don't know off the top of
my head with whatever crazy thing I've
signed with you these are the videos
that I put there so that's an
interesting question yeah you're
definitely the intellectual property
right the icy shores production biast
all that is yours yeah and you've
monetized it and I think from what I
understand you've gone into a
cooperative with YouTube I'm guessing
that they have the rights to it once you
do you sign over the rights but isn't
there anything to say like but this is
my video I've created this whether
that's been adjudicated or not I'm not
sure but I think the solution has to go
through the courts and this is me
believing the courts have been highly
politicized in what many many recent
years the long lasting legacy of Donald
Trump will be
hopefully the rebalancing the federal
judiciary away from slanted radicalism
and towards hopefully kind of very
restrained kind of restrained what's the
word textualism be more text to us and
so that's the question is so if
Elizabeth Warren starts to go on a
rampage you could you hopefully you can
be able to sue and you can use the
courts to uphold these things and that's
under you know under Obama there were
decisions that he what he was not crazy
about
so your basic belief if we were to
widdle all this down would be that the
three branches of government would still
be able to function in a way hopefully
we might not that would that would
protect us from the government let me go
a step further yeah there's four
branches of government and the fourth is
called Silicon Valley yeah and they're
stronger than the rest of three of them
that's that that's we're on that where
we have a super government that's been
created where the kingdom of DC is no
longer the most powerful fiefdom in this
game of Thrones that the power is in
Silicon Valley and this is where Tucker
is on this issue this is where Dennis
Prager is on this issue in the IRS to
give you 98 IRS they don't even accept
emails you have to you have to set a
snail letter to them like a listen snail
mail letter to them I again they might
be morally corrupted but these guys at
Google I mean they're literally building
new limbs for people right I mean
they've driverless cars highly
technological people and so indeed
here's my question for you as a
libertarian did you subdue support
looking retrospectively back in history
the trust-busting that Teddy Roosevelt
did in the 1900 right so I get it I mean
this is the slippery slope thing always
right there's a libertarian argument
that would be against the civil rights
act that I think is a no so I disagree
with the two and I'm not for relitigate
in it but I think there is there is a
libertarian argument there but this is
where I would say I would say this is
the difference between basically a
classical liberal and a libertarian I do
find some utility for the state so
nothing that you're saying to me you're
nothing you're saying is completely
outlandish sure and I think if anything
for whatever whatever disagreement there
is here in a weird way we need to keep
that disagreement do you think that's
fair to say because totally because that
way it keeps either side from in account
and not gonna get far not allowing your
emotion run and I think to keep it in
check
I just so it's very interesting converse
because the the growing in the kind of
conservative libertarian world and
reading Hayek and reading Rothbard I've
been told my entire life and I agree
with this up until the last couple
months where I've told the true monopoly
is government and it's just not true
anymore we have companies that could do
things the government cannot do yeah and
that's never been the case in human
history
it just never been the case it just
hasn't and where you have a government
that can shut off the entire lines of
communication for millions of people you
have a government that can say we want
everyone to think that Sam's deli is
closed tomorrow
so when Google's Sam's doubt I'll it's
closed even though it's open yeah that's
called your the entire super government
that's been created that can manipulate
the entire behavioral pattern of a
society and so if that actually if we
could admit that stronger than the
government then do we use government
against it and some and again I admitted
all of how that could go wrong you could
actually end up making those those
powerful but I want to go back to where
I see where I saw what a success looks
like and this this has to be like the
moonshot we're gonna get to the moon and
this is the advice I gave the President
Trump publicly where I think the
president should issue a big challenge
saying to the entrepreneurs of America
go start the next tech company I'm going
to use your platform I'm gonna use as
many platforms I can touch go do it
right now go raise the capital I believe
in you almost like creating
entrepreneurial activity around this
well Kirk as you know we're taping this
at the end of July right now this is
gonna air in August because I'm off the
grid for August you might be interested
in perhaps an announcement that someone
might be making at the beginning of
September I don't want to say too much
but that but if you want to ping that
Trump guy and tell them sure but yes I
love all that stuff and I'm not I'm not
saying any Young's are exclusive yeah
I'm saying we've we've identified the
problem we understand the significance
of it we understand how we could solve
it incorrectly because the first thing
you do in medicine is what first do no
harm
that's the first thing so we have this
problem and we could end up actually
making it worse and that would be
horrible wouldn't it imagine if we
passed all this regulation measures we
had this crazy bill passed through
Congress we felt great about then 18
months later all of a sudden we find out
that Google got all these last-minute
and it's not being enforced and they're
ending up not 92% of search results they
have 99% of search results and everyone
gets taken off the market and that would
be really that would be defeating the
road to hell man all right listen we
have to wrap one I'll go internally
obviously obviously we're doing this
again and you know look if we ended up
getting booted from the platform's I
guess we'll just have to keep doing this
in person until I get text this video to
people I don't know I'll take us down
Thank You charlie for more on charlie
follow him at charlie kirk 11 and don't
forget to click that subscribe button
and make sure the bail is solid to get
all the notifications for our videos
thanks for watching everybody
[Music]